c'est au tout chaud dans la renie tout
doux ça pourrait être les oeufs de la
pac 2018
à quelques heures près et qu'elle se
désintègre daigle pêcheurs également
appelé balbuzard car entre forêt
d'orléans et loire dame silva femelle
balbuzard de son état doit incessamment
pondre ça couvait de l'année après une
année 2010 est pleine de succès ce sont
les 3e que la femelle a pendu l'an
dernier avec un nouveau mal d'autres
savaient pas s'ils avaient vraiment la
maturité sexuelle et qui après ont éclos
et en donner trois jeunes qui ont grandi
et ont été jusqu'à l'envol donc
reproduction complètement réussi et
pourtant ce n'était pas gagné après la
disparition entre l'afrique et le loiret
du premier compagnon de silva
le mâle titulaire des années précédentes
n'a pas fait sa réapparition est donc un
jour elle a été captée en vol un jeune
migrant passagers
la ramener sur le nid et et sa
reconstituer un couple qui maintenant à
l'heure de partir pour une certaine
stabilité
bien évidemment il faut à tout cela un
certain confort ce qu'ils demandent
travail et savoir faire au début de
saison le bord du nil était beaucoup
plus bas et donc tout c'est toute cette
partie là et tout autour
ça a été rechargées donc ils vont casser
des branches mortes sur les armes il les
ramène il l'est dispose entre mêlée
jusqu'à ce que ça soit solide et après
ils garnissent la partie centrale qu'on
appelle la coupe du nil à garnissent
d'herbes sèches et c'est là que la
femelle va déposer ses yeux pour les
couvées vu à la télé grâce à la webcam
balbu cam point fr ces oiseaux sont
devenus des stars suivi par des milliers
d'amateurs les voir en vrai c'est une
autre histoire
à moins de 300 mètres leur vue d'aigle
et fait s'envoler et c'est bien ce qui
inquiète l'association marc diéval un
projet de route doit en effet frôlé
leurs arbres le projet routier e passera
50 m 2 derrière l'arbre convoi très
probablement le dérangement soit trop
fort un comble alors même que ces
migrateurs quasi disparu ont fait un
retour inespéré depuis quelques années à
peine dans le loiret et ne compte qu'une
vingtaine denis sur l'ensemble de la
forêt d'orléans